and we're uh joined today by Heather
McDonald she's the author of the recent
bestseller will en Ras Trump's Merit how
the pursuit of equity sacrifices
Excellence destroys Beauty and threatens
lives uh Heather thanks for joining us
it's an honor Matt uh yeah thanks for me
in was in fact it's it's fortunate we're
talking today because there's a couple
issues that have recently come up I
wanted to ask you about um but but first
you know you've been speaking out
against the the uh the race Hustlers and
the anti-racist grifters for a long time
of course how do you just from a General
perspective how do you assess the state
of that movement of that scam uh right
now
today I think it's still very strong
Matt uh despite the Supreme Court ruling
now you and I are both innate uh
pessimists but I'm sorry I do not see
any cessation of it amazingly the stem
Fields medicine continues to pump out
daily statements about medicine being
racist somebody just sent me a case
Western Reserve Medical School saying
saying we need to change the curriculum
of our medical school because of the
demographics of our student body we need
to be teaching humility we know what
that means that's I'm quoting the
verbatim that i' never heard that one
before uh but one can guess that it
means uh whites have to go around
apologizing for the alleged racism that
leads to disperate outcomes uh recently
the Oakland district attorney in Alama
County gave a training to the victim
Services units about how to not be
harmed by white victims the idea is that
if a white crime victim is seeking
redress that somehow that's going to
threaten uh staff of color so the war on
Western Civilization simply because it
is deemed too white and too male the war
on standards simply because they have a
disperate impact on blacks I do not see
it it falling off at all and I don't see
conservatives willing to stand up to the
race hustle and articulate what's really
going on so when you see well you
mentioned the Supreme Court ruling but
even uh many of these corporations that
have that it seems anyway from the
outside have have have some of them have
started to deemphasize some of the Dei
stuff they're pushing pretty heavily for
a couple of years uh when you when you
see that you don't see progress you see
but what's happening are they just kind
of pivoting because they realize that
certain certain methods aren't working
or or
what well they still have their
narcissist young employee Workforce that
has been brainwashed by K through2
education and put a Finishing Touch in
college that is on the lookout for
phantom signs of racism and sexism those
employees are not going to go away uh
and and corporate wives are not going
away which pushed their husbands to be
more woke uh so maybe they're going to
you know that we have now Edward Blum
who brought the suit against Harvard and
and un University of North Carolina
doing lawsuits against various law firms
that have uh blacks only Fellowship
programs and he just brought suit
against West Point for having racial
preferences and admissions if I were an
optimist I would say yes you know bring
it on we'll we'll sue people into
submission but that's peace and it also
puts an undue faith in the Judiciary you
know one of the most disturbing moments
for me in the uh Brett Kavanaugh
hearings that that tried to uh you know
run a a absolute superb jurist out of
the country basically was when you had
the students at the Harvard and Yale law
schools protesting with signs that said
believe survivors that ethic that female
who claims sexual assault is entitled to
automatic belief is the antithesis of
due process those graduates of Harvard
and Yale are being pumped onto the
federal Judiciary at way
disproportionate rates if they don't
change their thinking and I have no
reason to think they will we can't
assume redress from the courts uh in the
future so I I just think it's going to
take a hell of a lot more honesty than
I'm willing to that I've been able to
hear from our leaders what do you think
so culturally we have there's there's
sort of race and then there's also
there's also gender ideology these two
things are there's there's a lot of
overlap there of course they're related
but what do you think is for the
left which is the more potent uh vehicle
for you know cultural domination and for
and for and for getting their ideology
across and indoctrinating people into
their ideology because gender or race
what do you think is the more kind of
potent tool for them wow uh and and and
I'd also like your response to whether
you think things are improving I cannot
I cannot uh put a hierarchy on those on
the one hand the race hustle is a is is
giving an excuse to tear down
meritocratic standards across both the
stem Fields across the Arts across
theater across classical music certainly
uh in the criminal justice system if
people don't understand that disperate
impact is driving this perplexing
behavior of prosecutors that are
declaring
entire uh areas of criminal Behavior off
limits to prosecution they have to
understand it's all driven by race
because if they prosecute those crimes
in a colorblind constitutional fashion
they will have a disperate impact on
black criminals and the left has decided
it cares more about black criminals than
black victims so the the race hustle is
is allowing us to very quickly self-c
canell it is the the suicide of the west
but so is gender ideology gender
ideology what are we doing in a gay
pride March but celebrating
non-procreative sex we are celebrating
people who are not uh in in choosing
their their their preferred sexual
partners they are not engaged in
procreative Sex and and we're again it's
it's part of the Great replacement
Theory we are making sure that the West
simply self- cancels so they both are
operating at at very profound levels the
one tearing down Merit meritocratic
standards the ability of students to be
P pushed to accomplish at their highest
level we're tearing down gifted and
talented math education across the
country somebody just sent me something
from the Sequoia School District which
is around paloalto and Meno Park where
they are getting rid of advanced
placement courses or Advanced
accelerated courses in math science in
English because of disperate impact so
we're tearing that down but we're also
tearing down the basis of civilization
which is the family profiling
surveillance and data harvesting are a
few things not to like about tech Giants
but what can you actually do about it
when you rely on so many of their
products well the good news is doesn't
take much for you to take a stand for
less than $7 per month you can join me
and fight back against big Tech by using
expressvpn big tech companies make their
money by tracking your searches video
history and everything you click on and
then selling your personal data
expressvpn helps you anonymize much of
your online presence by hiding your IP
address a unique identifier that every
device has that allows big Tech to match
your activity back to you that's why I
use expressvpn on all my devices to make
it much more difficult for them to
exploit my data for their own profits
and the best part is how easy it is to
use the expressvpn app all you got to do
is tap one button on your phone or
computer and turn it on it's as simple
as that so your data is your business
visit expressvpn.com walshy use my Link
at expressvpn.com
Walt to get three extra months free
that's exprss vpn.com
walshy but let me turn it back to you do
you are you optimistic and which do you
think is of of of greater power as a
battering ram against civilization the
race hustle or the gender
ideology uh well I'm never optimistic so
that's an easy question easy easy
question for me to answer uh I basically
agree with you I think that I do think
that in certain areas you know it's a
little bit of a whack-a-mole thing so
there's certain areas where they've
they've had to Pivot and the left's very
good at this they rename things they
they realize that something something
has bad you know it's The Branding isn't
good anymore so they have to kind of
Rebrand you know the push back against
CRT was successful in a lot of ways but
it doesn't mean that that ideology is
just going to disappear and and they
still the powers that be in our country
still realize that this is a very potent
tool for uh profit for them and also for
control they're not just going to give
it up uh they certainly aren't and
between gender and race it's I'm not
exactly sure I think it's I think it is
basically impossible to to rank the two
so maybe I was asking you an impossible
question which isn't exactly Fair um
maybe I would say that longterm you know
maybe the race hustle maybe has longer
legs in the long term uh where right now
the gender seems to be maybe the more
tool for them at this exact moment so
maybe that's if I had to balance the two
maybe that's the way that I would do it
I I I agree I agree and I would just I
would qualify something you said which
is as a tool for profit and control
that's true and it is certainly true
that there are a lot of race Hustlers
who whose entire jobs depend on the idea
that being black is an accomplishment or
counterpart that being female is an
accomplishment I do I know that being
female is not an accomplishment and I
would also say that being gay is not an
accomplishment and being black is not an
accomplishment none of those things
should qualify anybody for a job and yet
they do again and again and again and
the idea that everything is caused by
systemic racism has given birth to a
vast uh Consulting scam but I think that
conservatives move a little too quickly
to to sort of an economic explanation
that oh this is all about profit or
whatever it is about control and
certainly we've seen that for uh the the
coid hysteria but it is also I think we
have to understand these are True
Believers I don't think that they are
adopting a a set of phony propositions
that they agree as such I think they
actually are committed to the idea that
uh the West is endemically racist and
the source of the world's problems
whereas in fact of course the opposite
is the case no civilization has Pro
provided as
much cerse from Pain suffering premature
death
squalor you know um cold famine than the
West I mean it's not even close it is
not even close everything just do a
little inventory leftists of your
apartment or home right now do an
inventory of every material every
electrical Appliance every labor saving
device your smart phones water you've
got clean water you can flip on a switch
and get light you're not overcome with
darkness which was the fate of human
beings for Millennia it's all thanks to
White overwhelmingly male scientists and
tinkerers that starting in the early
18th century some back in the 17th
century with the British Society were
fascinated to understand the world
developed the scientific method and gave
us this incredible
tapestry of excellence and comfort and
beauty that we live
with well said I think actually you
might have just tapped into one of the
potentially one of the critical
differences between going back to the
race and gender question because I think
I think you're right that the race
Hustlers uh certainly on the on on the
lower levels are are True Believers for
the most part and leftist in general
everything they say about race I mean
they I think they do basically believe
it they're confused enough to believe it
now on the other end the people that are
pushing a lot of this trans stuff uh and
the idea that that men can be women and
women can be men I think a lot of them
are don't really believe it because you
can't believe it because it's it's it's
so incoherent there's no way that you
really believe it especially if you're
an educated person in science you know
that this is not true so maybe that's
one of the differences that that the
gender stuff is being pushed by people
who who really are entirely cynical and
they don't believe it the the race stuff
is being pushed by True Believers maybe
well I get asked this all the time and
I'm sure you do too which is well tell
us what the inner State the psychology
or the epistemology of these people are
do they believe it and again my instinct
is to say that they do uh because I
can't imagine being that cynical
throughout your life that you are
deliberately like there's a a sequence
and maybe it's simply instantaneous
which is well I know this is all as
you've said many times this is an idea
that represents like a nano of a
millisecond of a of a like cilia within
the Millennia of human history and all
of a sudden it becomes the new default
that that men can menstrate and and and
females can procreate through penises
this is just
astounding but that that they would say
that I know it's fake and yet I'm going
to now go and and Destroy childhood
innocence through the premature exposure
to of children to sexuality I don't even
care if it's heterosexual or or trans or
or lgbtq sexuality children should be in
that zone of innocence and I know again
I am just repeating one of the most
crucial themes that you have been
educating your listeners about which is
that you as parents have a duty to
preserve your children's innocence and
their capacity for imagination as long
as possible because it will provide them
a Haven from Despair and ugliness as
adults uh but I I can't imagine that
people would be that cynical to say I
don't believe it but I'm going to pursue
these
policies uh
anyway let me ask you uh I think it's
very important to to equip people with
arguments and that's what I try to do of
course you you do great job job with
that in all of your books anyone
listening right now we've talked about
systemic racism and that's a big part of
the whole race hustle um I think many
normal people when they hear about
systemic racism intuitively they don't
believe it because they can look around
at society and and see that like where
where is this where is this systemic
racism but what what you'll hear from
the other what you hear from the other
side is that well it's it's ingrained in
the system there's the vestiges of of
racism in the past the system was set up
originally by racist people and so it's
still and you have the SP impact as you
mentioned so so how I know it's a broad
question but but um how would you
suggest people deal with that and
respond to that
argument well I would first start out
and you're right systemic racism that
you know there used to be this
scientific theory of fistan which was
this kind of colorless substance that
was just assumed to be existing and it
was used as the catall explanation for
any physical process you couldn't
understand and it had no existence it
was just it was a placeholder for
ignorance uh and you had the miasma
theory of of infection all these things
that were discredited systemic racism
works the same way when you don't want
to acknowledge the actual causes of
disperate outcomes which is the academic
skills Gap uh you invoke systemic racism
but you can never actually prove it uh
per se you can't find it you can't see
it but it it's the fallback explanation
what I would first say is okay this idea
that we remaining a discriminate a
racist Society show me any institution
that is not twisting itself into knots
to hire and promote as many blacks as
possible how can it be that we're told
that universities say You must allow us
to continue with racial preferences
because if we don't have them we will
not be able to get our desired critical
mass of blacks and so they are willing
to lower lower their academic standards
to an extraordinary degree to admit
black students and then the pressure is
ubiquitous and constant in every
academic hiring search to find uh the
few blacks who have graduated with phds
in electrical engineering which ends up
being in the stem Fields about 1% at
most uh of phds in in stem fields are
granted to blacks and in many fields
they're
none uh but the pressure is on to hire
those few that are out there and they
get enormous bidding wars in salaries of
course the pressure is also on to hire
females in stem and and females get
hired ahead of males at rates like at
some places 3 to One how can it be that
these are racist institutions it's it's
it's literally a logical
contradiction that they are so so
determined to have blacks in them that
they are bending their standards and yet
at the same time they're discriminating
against blacks it does not compute and
anybody that is vaguely aware of of his
workplace if he's in a law firm say an
elite law firm knows that the name of
the game is how do black Associates are
are hired out of law school at rates
disproportionate to whites they're hired
with lower class ranking and the
pressure is constant from both the
American Bar Association and internally
from firms to promote those into blacks
into into firm Partners now of course
there are thousands of blacks who are
out committing out competing whites and
Asians thousands they are getting by on
their hard work on their
self-discipline uh so I don't want to
say that this is a you you know a
problem that has no exceptions but given
the reality of of mismatch when you
bring people into an institution that
have lower academic skills than their
peers they're going to struggle and that
happens both in academic environments
and it happens in places like law firms
so there black Associates who were hired
on the basis of race end up leaving the
law firm because they're not keeping up
but nevertheless you can look at the law
firms and say all they care about is
racial proportionality and we're
supposed to believe they're racist
please explain that and here is what the
explanation is that people need to hear
and Matt I mean I realize that this
entire
conversation is very difficult for
people to observe to witness to
participate in because we have very
strong race etiquette in this country
another way of disproving the white
supremacy argument you know it is not as
you've said before it is not the
behavior of white supremacists to turn
their eyes away from black onwhite
violence and to pretend that the problem
in this country is white on black
violence when
87% of all interracial violence between
blacks and whites and whites and blacks
is committed by blacks when blacks are
35 times more likely to commit a violent
assault against a white than a white is
against a black it's not the behavior of
white supremacist to not look at that
but here I'm sorry these are
uncomfortable facts but here's the EXP
ation for ongoing racial disparities in
meritocratic fields like stem or law or
or corporate Hightech Finance you know
Silicon Valley Engineers here's the data
12 if you look at black 12th graders
66% of all black 12th graders do not
possess even partial Mastery of basic
12th grade math skills defined as being
able to do arithmetic or read a
graph
7% of black 12th grade uh students are
proficient in math and the number who
are
Advanced is too small in a national
sample to even show up
statistically that makes the
expectation of equal outcomes absent
racism simp simply impossible it cannot
be done the fact of the matter is you
can have diversity or you can have
meritocracy you cannot have both in
light of current academic skills gaps
and any institution that loudly
proclaims that it is behind diversity
and diversity Equity inclusion and
belonging are its prime values is
telling you soov voce that it is
lowering standards and is cast decide
Med
meritocracy on meritocracies let me this
the last question I want to ask you on
that on that topic because you talk
about Merit the need to assess People
based on Merit the equity uh pushers
will will say that we can't assess
everybody we can't assess everyone
equally based on Merit because we're not
all starting from the same place this is
C Harris's line and she didn't come up
with it obviously but the difference
between equality and Equity is you know
equality is the assumption that we're
all starting from the same place and so
you you just treat everyone the same and
give them you know let people be free
and and that's equality but the problem
was we can't do that because some people
are starting the race farther up the
track and so Equity is to put everyone
at the same starting point which means
boosting some people ahead of time uh so
that so that then we can have from there
an equal race um how do you how do you
respond to that absurd
claim well if the if the disparities
diminish over time and you gave people
preference you know you admitted black
students to selective colleges with
20000 difference in SATs a standard
deviation and by the end of the four
years or six years uh they had caught up
uh you know that may that would be
something that we should definitely
consider uh because it would show that
well you can close the disparities this
late in life but it doesn't happen in
fact the opposite is the case you are
putting a handicap on students it is the
racial preferences are incredibly cruel
and sadistic they are the most cruel
policy of these damn College presidents
and administrators because they are
putting a unique burden on black
students to be catapulted in academic
environments for which they're not
qualified and in which they will
predictably struggle and fall behind
this is not about race it's simply about
academic mismatch and let me put it in
the context of sex let's say
MIT uh wants more females in its
undergraduate class and that's not a
hypo hypothesis of course it does every
school that's a tech school is obsessed
with gender and so it has gender sex
preferences and it admits me with SATs
on my math score of 600 on an 800 point
scale whereas my peers are all admitted
basically with 800s my male peers
because they've been admitted based on
Merit and I've been admitted based on my
sex well what's going to happen in my
freshman year I'm going to struggle
because the teaching is understandably
and legitimately pitched at the average
skill of my classmates which is very
high and I'm likely to say I can't keep
up I'm dropping out of a stem field I'm
going to I'm going to major in mit's
gender studies department and of course
the diversity bureaucrats will be ready
at hand to tell me that I'm the victim
of misogyny and rape culture and that's
why I'm not keeping up the same thing
happens with black students they are
catapulted with much greater academic
skills gaps into schools for which
they're not competitively qualified if
they had been admitted to schools with
the same skills as their
peers let's say instead of getting into
MIT they went to Boston College or
Boston
University uh or instead of University
of North Carolina Chapel Hill went to a
university uh a North Carolina state
school that was less prestigious they
would do just fine and that's what
everybody else does you know it's not
the end of the world to not go to an
elite Ivy League school Believe It or
Not College presidents you bunch of
elitist snarling curs it is possible to
get a decent education and to become a
leader at a second and third tier school
so the idea that because maybe we don't
start ahead we have to at the end of the
at the end of the process lower our
standards a it doesn't work and B here's
what's happening when we lower standards
we are now lowering standards for the
medical school licensing exam part one
because blacks don't do well enough on
it so we've gone from a great gred it's
called step one of the US medical
licensing exam it used to be graded as
of 2021 January it went to pass fail
basis so we would cover up the ongoing
skills Gap black medical students were
doing the worst in their classes they
were not Landing their preferred
residencies so we've decided we'll just
get rid of those standards the pressure
is on throughout Medical School uh to
change standards for medical licenses
the curriculum is being changed the
Honor Society uh credentials are being
changed the the there's less and less
time being devoted to clinical practice
and understanding how to save a body
that's been crushed in a car accident
and more time students are spending
learning about systemic racism in
medical school so if you care about
whether you're going to get the best
qualified doctor walking through that ER
or whether you've got the best qualified
oncologist trying to finally solve the
mystery of cancer or the best qualified
neurologist trying to save human beings
from the scourge of Alzheimer's disease
it ain't
happening the federal government is
giving grants for science research based
on race not based on skill we are
slowing down our progress meanwhile
China is barreling ahead at at Mock
speed with its math education with its
Science Education it is finding its most
talented students throwing everything
it's got at them and saying go whoop
America's ass and it is
happening yeah well and and I would also
note that uh you said really you don't
have to go to I school at all you can
survive yet actually you can go to no
school you can go to no college at all
and still survive as as as I've
discovered well there's a lot more that
we can say about this of course uh and
you say a lot more in your book when
race Trump's Merit and that can be
picked up anywhere you get books
including Amazon Heather McDonald thanks
thanks again really appreciate it I
appreciate it mate thank you so
much